oh banana banana who i have a banana
wait where's my banana oh here's a
banana it's a sad banana
i traumatized it earlier i don't
i don't know if people want to see it's
like it's
it's brown earlier i was doing a photo
shoot with
banana and the chessboard and here's uh
here's like tomorrow's youtube thumbnail
so so what what i was doing i kept
throwing the banana
at the the king and it took
it took dozens of throws to like get
this uh this shot
i set up the camera at like super high
speed
so it takes maybe like 20 photos in one
second
um and now now the banana's all bruised
i'm not sure if i should if i should eat
it or just throw it away
or i could make like i could make banana
smoothie
i think i don't know would people want
this as like a a poster
like a motivated whoa it's it's a giant
number of money
worry about carrot email
donating a hundred dollars telling me
not to worry
thanks so much i i appreciate the
support i'll i'll do my best not to
worry
i just have to take deep breaths and
drink tea
okay let's go back let's play let's play
silo simon
played once before let's play this
opening
trying to think what to play i could
play and there's so many options
i'll play another scotch
let's see what what black is up to
against the scotch oh
queen h4 oh that's funny someone was
asking about this line earlier it may
have been silo simon i don't know
so this is objectively dubious
but it's very dangerous if white doesn't
know how to deal with it
so the threat is of course to take i'm
gonna play the best move
and yeah this is a very critical
position
and the best move is not obvious here
because again black is ready to take
or take and then take bishop d3 loses
the knight
and so does bishop d2 so the best move
is bishop e2
as far as i know
and then i'm willingly
gambling upon f3 is not legal
because it's pinned which is another
benefit to
the queen being here so actually when i
when i first started playing the scotch
i i was in high school
and i competed in this high school state
team championship
and i had two games in the same
tournament
that featured this exact line
i think this exact position black may
have taken
it's it's going to be the same thing um
i remember having like studied the like
this line before the tournament
so it paid off um
black's already in trouble here i'm
threatening to to win the pawn
and there's really no great move to
defend the pawn without without
blundering something
or making some like big concession
so this is probably an opening i should
i should probably make like a designated
video on
i will say okay the the most common
moves here are this
this this or this so i really don't care
if my if my opponent's like
watching in and and sees that these are
the options so queen e5 is um
yeah it's one of the worst moves because
of f4
even though it looked like it was
defending the problem now is
the queen can't stay defending the pawn
and i'll be winning the
the rook
oh if queen g so if we g2 good question
i should have also labeled this and
bishop f3
attacks the queen defends a rook and i'd
be guaranteed to
to win c7
wait did i get baited or my opponent got
baited
oh maybe my opponent got baited i did
draw this arrow
the best move was king d8 which i also
drew
so um
that was only moved to like not lose
this pawn
it is fun sometimes though to suggest
like really bad moves
and watch them play it
but a lot of people will play queen e5
without uh listening in
and i'm i'm sure there's probably at
least a hundred games
if not more where black has fallen into
this trap
online
oh you got baited into thinking you got
baited
oh
wait are you just trying to bait me yet
again
or did that actually happen i don't know
okay let's win a rook
yeah it's baitception
alexa what does jabated mean
debated is a form of the word debate as
a noun
debate is usually defined a discussion
as of a public question in an assembly
okay alexa quiet
all right let's save the knights
i'm not really scared of this because
then i play bishop d2 and defend the
rook
and attack the queen i just want to
bring the knife back
hey it's chad pecker just found me just
found me
like how recently from
from youtube
oh you love the commentary nice
yeah i usually like to mix it up i'll
sometimes do
like earlier today i was doing i played
in the title arena
which was all one minute chess but
tonight
it's a bit more chill um
[Music]
hopefully a bit more instructive oh
so if i do this takes takes then i'm
actually losing back the rook
oh
let's try it
it looks aggressive
oh no my rook yeah i can't play bishop
d2 anymore because my queen now my queen
is no longer defending
da
so i i gave up casting rights
i lose a rook but i win a queen
it's abated yeah i had to see that
i had to see that a few moves earlier
this is beautiful
so much beauty and black sadness
[Music]
oh no my pawn i forgot the queen was
defending the pawn
oh no ah the pawn is so lonely oh but
black doesn't take it
ah i blundered the pawn yet again
please just take it
hello future me laughing while watching
on youtube
do i put this on youtube i feel bad
i yeah i don't know how to feel about
debating people
because on one hand it's really
satisfying
but i know like people are suffering
because of it
but it's still satisfying thanks for the
game silo simon
yeah next time in general you should
really only play this line
against noobs um
it's very effective against lower low
rated players
um
it's something i might consider playing
myself as black depending on the
situation
but if we just see how many people fell
into this on the chest
yeah so we can see like if white doesn't
play bishop e2 then
i guess knight b5 is also possible here
but there's a lot of ways i can go wrong
oh i was honestly just kinda curious
what the refuge oh that's interesting
thanks for crushing my dubious opening
yeah yeah this opening like it has kind
of a clear
i guess a very clear refutation um
and it's good like if you play this
opening you you know the worst case
scenario
which is bishop e2
um and this is still
wait what does stockfish recommend
oh the so cyprus just recommends yeah
not even taking the pawn
i have the impression that it's okay to
take but here
you really have to you can start by
taking but then k8
it's still playable i box up a pawn
white white has very good compensation
but it's not
completely dead engine will give
some plus for white
but it's very much a fight
so anyway um if this goes on youtube
youtube people beware
of playing dubious openings don't get
debated
and follow on twitch and i'll see you in
the future